We talked about calculating totals for a student, but there was another
important use for this 2D array. We wanted to be able to tell if there was a
particular topic that my friend needed to spend more time on. Let's write a
method that calculates the sum for each column. So it would return an array
whose size matches the number of topics. And those values should be the some of
all of the students scores for that topic. So in this case, the array would
look like this. If you're ready to go this method, skip ahead. If not, I'll do
a short example first. Let's say I want to calculate the total for multiplying
fractions. I would want to add this this spot, and this spot, and this spot.
This one is the zeroth student, and the second topic. This one is the first
student, and the second topic. This one, is the second student, and the second
topic.